hello Internet i'm dave rubin this is
the rubin report and we have a young
turks all-star edition ana kasparian
jimmy dore we didn't even need a third
person because of the breadth of your
knowledge and egos do you normally have
a third person we normally have a third
girl okay well I'll talk double you can
do to people you can do impressions
whatever you want to do alright sounds
all of you know once in a while genk
will come in I'll just impersonate him
Jane can jump in it all right welcome to
The Young Turks so every so awesome yeah
well you guys know how it works and
you're comfortable at this table so here
we go alright first story North Korea
now by the time this story gets up on
YouTube we could have been decimated in
a nuclear war they are threatening to
preemptively strike us they are moving
people added the embassies they want
diplomats out of the country by April
10th it is a big mess but we sort of
think it feels a little jokey to me what
do you guys think what do we do about
this North Korea madness I think that at
this point it's common knowledge that
North Korea doesn't have the nuclear
capabilities necessary to actually
attack the United States they've been
threatening the United States for quite
a while now the question is are they
going to attack South Korea and of
course that's it's entirely possible uh
North Korea is not a rational actor as
it was as we all know so if there's a
possibility that this is gonna end badly
but the question is what should the role
be of the United States at this point
and any experience I've had in the past
is when the US gets involved in
something internationally it doesn't end
well nothing good right ever comes out
of it and the reason why North Korea is
threatening the u.s. to begin with is
because they don't like some of the
military exercises that US soldiers are
doing with South Korean soldiers celery
jumping jacks yeah they don't like the
jumping jacks they're very offended by
that it's intimidating yeah so I don't
know what the US is gonna do I just hope
that they don't act prematurely and do
something so yeah Jimmy do you consider
immaturely something I know about yeah
do you consider Kim jong-un an
irrational actor I consider Mel Gibson
to be an irrational actor that Kim Jung
Woo oh you know I took to me the funnest
part about this whole story was that it
got started with Dennis Rodman yeah
going over there and people were upset
with him because and you know I thought
he was perfect ambassador material but
uh turns out he wasn't and then he went
on George snuffleupagus his show and he
held his he was like do you what about
his his human rights violations and
Dennis Rodman was like sitting there
with sunglasses on huh what are you
smoking by play basketball and he said
don't you feel like you have a
responsibility to ask him about the you
know the toughest question I expected
Dennis Rodman to ask is is this north or
south korea yeah that's what I expect
yeah is it this though isn't this part
of the problem that we Stennis Rodman's
over there Kim Jong own looks the way he
looks like it all seemed this seems like
a movie it doesn't seem real so when
they're like oh we're gonna preemptively
nuclear strike you whether they can or
can't it seems made up this seems silly
doesn't sound silly especially when we
know you know some of the crazy behavior
of the you know dictator of North Korea
how crazy his father was I mean
anonymous did something that I found
hilarious they hacked into their
intranet yes they're not really part of
the Internet yeah and just like the word
in try to I didn't like that and they
had like a web page where they had a
picture of une with a Mickey Mouse
tattoo on his stomach of course they
photoshopped it and like pig ears and
like a pig nose and it was hilarious so
like the entire thing even though their
threats seem serious and they sound
scary I mean people have handled it in
such a funny way the way Anonymous has
handled it was hilarious so I think
that's part of the reason why no one's
really taking the threats that seriously
i I really don't take them seriously I
can't believe anyone would so he saw
that he launches a nuclear missile
what's his next move right right then
his country's over right so it won't
even let that's why it's funny to hear
like people whose the news defense
secretary I'm blanking out his name
robert gates no that's the old one no
Rob you're right that is going on Chuck
Hagel there you go so he was talking
like this with this time it's
serious and where I'm like really this
time I don't understand why they
pretended like it was serious yeah he's
never gonna do anything is there any
part of you that emphasizes a little bit
with North Korea because why do we have
30,000 troops right on their border were
flying b-52s like forget all the
intricacies that we don't we're not
really pretty too but a little bit of we
have a military why do we have 30,000
troops uh right next door to that cuz
they're crazy that [ __ ] cray like look I
look I know that part of the reason why
there's a lot of hostility toward the
United States is because we love to go
into other countries we have no business
being there and uh you know we love to
meddle in their business but at the same
time North Korea has been threatening us
for quite a while so I can understand
why the US would want to have some sort
of military presence on the border yeah
uh but you know at the same time like I
definitely don't think the US should
like invade North Korea anytime soon or
do anything crazy uh I I don't even
think that the US should get too
involved without you know the conflict
with South Korea and North Korea because
that's what we always do we love to take
a side and then we take aside there's
hostility toward the United States
because of the side that we've taken of
course Jimmy final word when does the
war begin there's no war it's not gonna
happen you don't get impacts that other
point about why are we even there I just
think it's because once we're somewhere
we never leave anywhere right we're
still in Japan we're still in Germany
with the only land troops or seventy
thousand troops in Germany yes chairman
germany i was there i was like this is
not you guys have a nice place here and
then they have the US military has their
own huge Airport they have their own
it's yeah I'm like right in the middle
of another country there what are we
doing there is it really just because
the military industrial complex is so
big and it's like we're just never gonna
take these people home never gonna take
them they have hospitals there they have
I mean American bases I mean it's really
it's nice over there yeah
bonobos calm is the official outfitter
of the Ruben report enter code trr 20
for twenty percent off your first
purchase